ELLIE POWERS: OK, so
as Chris mentioned,
I'm going to talk
to you about how
to build your app for success.
And one of the
things that we find
is most associated with a high
level of success on Google Play
is high quality.
Users definitely appreciate
high quality apps.
And we want to make sure that
you have all the information
that you need to make
sure that your apps meet
this high-quality bar.
So one of the reasons that
I'm most excited about being
a product manager on
Google Play is that today,
if you have an
idea or a business
that you want to get out
into the world, the best way
to do that is
through mobile apps,
and also through Google Play,
because we have the largest
global reach.
So let's talk a little
bit more about what
quality means for mobile apps.
We're going to walk through
each stage of the software
development cycle, from
designing your app,
to developing your app,
to distributing your app.
And we're going
to talk about how
you can bring out the
high level of quality
at each of these stages.
So first off, we're going
to start with design.
And one thing to know
about Google Play
is that users have
really been trained
and evolved to appreciate high
quality, beautiful design.
Earlier this year, with
the launch of Lollipop,
we announced this new concept,
which Chris talked about,
which we call material design.
Now the idea here
is it represents
a new design paradigm
that helps you
understand how to build
excellent experiences
from device to device.
So if you have a
certain experience
that you want to have work
great across your website
and your different mobile apps
across different platforms,
you can use material
design to help
give them a consistent
look, feel, and experience.
Also if a user has
an Android L device,
this is essential to
fitting in and making
your app feel that it really
belongs on this device.
So first, before we
get into the details,
we're going to talk about
the different reasons
why material design is
helpful and why you want
to consider it for your app.
So first of all,
material design is
all about bright
and bold colors,
which can be very useful in
expressing your company's
brand.
Second, it's a great
way to delight users.
Users want to feel
that the app really
fits in with the other apps
in their Android device,
and material design
helps you do that.
It also helps you create strong
cross platform or strong device
experiences where the user
will have a similar experience
whether they're on a phone,
a tablet, TV, and so on.
And finally, this represents
an opportunity for your apps
to get discovered.
Many developers have already
adopted material design.
And we're featuring
some of the best
examples in our beautiful
design collection.
Eventually, if you want your app
to get featured on Google Play,
you'll need to make sure that
it includes material design as
well.
So right now, it's a good
chance to get started early.
Here's an example of how the
Gmail team has redesigned
the Gmail app to adopt the
principles of material design.
Let's take a look at
what they've done here.
So on the left is the old
version and on the right
is the new version.
You can see that the new
version looks much cleaner.
They've given a lot
more white space,
so it doesn't feel as
heavy or cluttered.
They've added a bright color.
You can see the red
bar across the top.
And also the red button on
the lower right-hand corner
means that the message
composition button is very easy
to find and jumps out.
It just looks great too and
feel a lot nicer to use.
Second, this is an example
of how the Google Play Music
app has been redesigned.
Again here, you'll notice
the bright use of color,
drawing from each of
the different album art,
emphasizing one of the most
prominent colors there.
It looks really clean and nice.
And also when you
interact with the app,
you can see the use
of motion really
helps make the user understand
the different transitions
as they browse the
different music
collections on their tablet.
And here we have the
Play Store as well.
We recently updated the
Play Store earlier this year
to take advantage
of material design.
So if you compare
again the old version
on the left with the new
version on the right,
you can see that we've
added a beautiful banner
graphic across the
top, which really
gives the users a great
view and a beautiful imprint
of your brand.
Secondly, we've added a
short text description
across the bottom to help users
get a quick summary of what
your app does.
And in the middle, we're using
bright colors and bold icons
to show the user several
reasons why to install your app.
So now we're going to talk
about the four different design
principles behind
material design--
tangible surfaces, meaningful
and delightful motion,
bold and beautiful aesthetics,
and adaptive design.
So first, tangible surfaces.
So again here the
idea is about creating
this idea of how physical
objects would react
in the physical world
and trying to express it
in a computer interface.
So you can have areas
of light and shadow.
You can also use the layout
to separate the content
from the navigation.
And interactions
should be given cues.
So if you have a
user interface, you
can use visual cues
to let the user know
how the app will respond
in response to their touch.
Second, we have the bold
and beautiful aesthetics.
So this can be use of beautiful
typography, whatever typography
fits your brand,
bold use of color,
and we also put
a lot of emphasis
on content and material design.
Here you can see an example
of the Play Music app.
We're using the album
art cross the top.
And we're taking that bright
pink color that comes right
from the content and using that
to bring a bright highlight
to the different
buttons on the screen.
We also like to
use geometric icons
that help give a consistent look
and feel between different apps
in the user's device.
Next up is my favorite, which
is meaningful and delightful
motion.
Here the idea is that you
want the app to really feel
like it's responding
to the user's touch.
So you don't want
to distract the user
by having too much motion, but
you do use this as a great way
to make your apps feel much more
fun and much more interactive.
Finally, we have
adaptive design.
The main principle
that we want to have
here is if a user accesses your
app on their Android device,
on another mobile
platform, or on the web,
even if they've never used that
platform before, they should
have an intuitive sense of
how it will work if they've
used your app somewhere else.
So when they move
from screen to screen,
they'll be able to see
some consistent elements.
And you'll want to think
about exactly which elements
to show on each screen.
But again, the idea
is that they have
a consistent, underlying
principle that the user can
learn to understand.
So now what we're going to do
is talk about different device
types and how you
can specifically
tune your apps to work great
across these different devices.
And the first one we're going
to talk about is tablets.
We've seen that most
apps, especially
in the global market, are
already designed for tablets.
And this is great to see.
They make sure that users
have a great experience
and really take advantage
of the larger screen size
that they have on tablets.
When you upload your app to the
Google Play Developer Console,
we actually scan
it automatically
to make sure that it meets some
basic requirements to ensure
that users will have a
good experience on tablets.
You can upload screenshots
of how your app will look
on 7-inch and 10-inch devices.
And if you want to make
sure that your app has
maximum visibility and
discoverability on the Play
Store and tablets,
you need to make sure
that you do meet the design
for tablets guidelines.
And if you go to
developer.android.com--
that's a website you're going
to hear about a lot today--
we have specific guidelines
to help you understand
what makes a great tablet app.
Next up we have Android Wear.
This is getting
a lot of interest
in terms of smart watch usage.
And you actually have
three different ways
of how you can implement
an Android Wear app.
We're going to talk about each
of your different options one
by one.
So the most basic
version is if your app
is using our standard
notifications platform,
notifications are
just going to work.
But you will want to
make sure you try it,
so you may want to try
getting an Android Wear device
and make sure that the
notifications are showing up
the way you want them to.
Secondly, if you're just getting
started with Android Wear
and you want to do
something that's
going to be easy and quick,
with as little as about
10 lines of code, you can
create enhanced notifications.
And this can help you reformat
your notifications using things
like pages or stacking.
And you can even
integrate voice replies.
We've seen a lot of
interest in Android Wear.
And users are really excited
about things, especially
like messaging
apps, for example,
where it can be pretty easy
to show the new message
notification on the
watch, and then the user
can respond directly from their
watch using the voice reply.
Now if you want to build a
full-blown Android Wear app,
that's fantastic.
So I wanted to share
a couple of tips
with you that we've seen
from some of our partners
who have gotten started
early with Android Wear.
So those of you who have
built software before
may notice that the
graph on the left
seems like what you hope at
the beginning of the project.
You think, I'll just need
a small amount of time
from design, I'll spend most
of my time building the app,
and maybe I'll need
a little bit of time
at the end for debugging.
But what actually
ends up happening
is you need more design
time than you expected,
you still have to build the
app, but then at the end,
you need a lot more debugging
than you had expected.
Now, one thing that's
really important
when you think about
an Android Wear app
is that this type of
interaction is just
so different from
mobile apps or web pages
that you've done in the past.
So to make the best
experience, you
need to make sure that you
have some UX iteration time.
So the idea here is that
you build an early prototype
of your app, you get
an Android Wear device,
and you try it out at
home or at the office.
And then you say, well, that
doesn't quite work right.
And so you tweak
the interaction.
If you do this, you're
going to have a great result
and be very happy
with it, but it
does take a little bit of
extra work at the beginning.
Next up we have Android TV.
This is a great way to get
in users' living rooms.
We have the Nexus Player
device that's already launched.
And there's going to be a
lot more interest and devices
coming up in the future.
So there are three
principles here
that you want to keep in mind
when you're building for a TV.
So again the idea here is that
the TV in your living room
is not like a phone
or a desktop computer.
The user just wants
to get in very quickly
and get into their content.
So you don't want to put a lot
of interface between the user
and the television program or
the game that they want to use.
Also, you need to have a
much simpler interaction.
The user is going to be using
a remote control or a game
controller rather
than a touch screen,
so you'll need to do some
special testing to make sure
that the user can access all
of the different elements
in the UI.
Also you want the experience
to be very cinematic.
So the idea is the user wants
to sit back on their sofa
and watch the TV,
and they don't want
to be doing a lot
of interaction.
So we provide the Leanback
theme to give a consistent style
to your Android TV apps.
And we definitely recommend
that you use them.
Once you've created a
great Android TV app,
you can submit it to the
Google Play Developer Console,
and we'll check it
out to make sure
that it will provide
that great experience.
OK, so we talked
about how to design
your apps with quality in mind.
And next we're going to talk
about how to bring quality
to the development process.
So Lollipop came out
earlier this year.
And we're really
excited about it,
because it has the largest
number of new APIs compared
to any other Android release
we've had in the past.
This is really exciting.
So I'll tell you about a couple
of the main things that come up
in Android L. First of all,
we have material design,
which we've already discussed.
Second, we've made
a lot of changes
to the notifications platform.
We've also made a lot of
performance optimizations,
especially around
battery, Bluetooth,
and network efficiency, so
that if a user's connection is
flaky or keeps getting
dropped, the device
will be more responsive.
So let's talk a little bit
more about notifications in L.
These are some
things that we want
to make sure that
you're aware of
and you check your
applications for.
First of all, you'll
notice immediately
that the background of
notifications has changed.
It used to be that the
background color was black,
now the background
color is white.
You also get to have a
customized accent color.
So here, in this example,
this alarm clock notification
has a blue circle.
And you can customize the
color there to suit your brand
and whatever works for you.
Second, you want to add
a notifications flag
to the manifest,
because in Android L,
users can go in to
the Settings panel
and be able to
manage notifications
for each of your apps.
And you'll want your
app to be there.
Finally, we have a new
feature in Android L
where notifications can be
shown on the Lock screen.
This is a great way
to engage users.
But one thing to
be aware of is you
want to make sure
that you're presenting
the right information to a user.
You wouldn't necessarily want
to show private information
on the Lock screen.
So we have special
visibility settings
so that you can set the
private, the public,
and the secret views
for your notifications.
This will make sure the user
gets the right information when
they expect it.
Next up, one of
the things that's
so exciting about
working on Android
is we really have the
potential to connect everybody
in the world online using
mobile phone technology.
And this is super
exciting for us.
But here's a couple
tips that developers
need to keep in
mind if they want
to have a high-quality app
that gives a quality experience
in these emerging markets.
The first thing is that data
plans are typically very
expensive and hard for people
to afford in emerging markets.
So in order to help
people out, you
want to make sure that you
keep the size of your APK
as small as possible.
And secondly, don't think
about 3G access or LTE access.
Think about your user having
only 2G access and probably not
Wi-Fi access at all.
You'll want to make sure that
you do a good amount of testing
to make sure that your app
will be very responsive
and give the user
a clear experience,
even if the network
disconnects frequently or has
very slow access.
Finally, another area
that's important to test
is memory usage.
Typically these devices
in emerging markets
have a lower memory
than we are used to.
So you'll want to make sure
that you use different memory
testing tools to make
sure that the app is still
going to work great.
Android Studio Beta
is something that
is providing a lot of
these tools to do testing.
For example, it provides
this memory monitor tool
that can be really helpful
for that memory testing
that we just talked about.
It's also really
helpful in terms
of creating new device
type apps, so apps
for Android Wear or Android TV.
It also helps add a lot
of the Google services
that users in the
global market expect.
And it provides a lot of tools
to look at performance issues,
usability issues,
version compatibility,
and typical problems that
developers could run into.
So you want to make sure that
you do all this testing earlier
before you've launched your app.
For many of us, when
we're launching a new game
or application, we have
a really great idea,
but we don't have a big
budget to be able to build
a serious backend.
And that's where the Google
Cloud Platform comes in.
So it helps you launch quickly.
And then if your
app or game starts
to take off and gain
a lot of traction,
it's easier to get more quota
and be able to keep scaling
your game without
doing a lot of work.
It offers this great,
fast performance that
is typical of Google networks.
And it also offers
global access.
So this is a great
thing if you're
having an application
available on the global market
to make sure that users can
access this backend service
near where they are.
And to help you
get started, we're
offering something called
the Mobile Starter Kit.
So this is a special
offering from Google
to make the Google Cloud
Platform easier to afford
and easier to set up.
So Google Play
services is something
that's really exciting.
This is a way to give
access to all the Google
services on the user's device.
So this is automatically
kept up to date.
But with Google, you
don't have to put
any SDK into your app itself.
And we've launched several
new features in it this year.
For example,
activity recognition
is a special API that
allows you to see
if users are running, walking,
or doing other activities.
And then there's
also Cloud Save,
which is a great feature,
especially if you're
building a game and you
want to sync the user
state to the cloud.
It even works and
synchronizes well,
even if the user goes
offline or online.
OK, so we talked about
design and development.
And now we're going to talk
about all the different tools
that Google Play can use to help
you improve your app's quality
as you distribute it globally.
So we mentioned earlier
that the Google Play Store
has been updated to take
advantage of the new material
design look.
So if you're a developer,
there's a couple of key things
that you need to know
about to make sure
that this page is going to
look really great for you.
One of them is that
you need to make sure
that you've uploaded a large
banner graphic, which will be
shown at the top of the screen.
You can see here it's the one
with the dark blue background.
And this is a new
graphic that not everyone
will have uploaded before.
Secondly, we also have
a short text summary
at the bottom of each page.
So you'll need to make sure
that you've entered that text
description as well.
And this gives the
user a quick summary
to understand what the app does.
OK.
Hello.
Are we stuck?
There we go.
Great.
So user ratings are
something that's
really important on Google Play.
Users frequently
use ratings when
they're comparing
multiple apps and trying
to decide which one to install.
And so one thing our most
successful developers
tell us is that they
want to understand how
they can improve their reviews.
And they put a lot of time
into reading those reviews,
understanding the
complaints that users have,
reading user requests
for new features,
and then a special feature
that we have on Google Play
is that you can actually post
replies to your user reviews.
So if a user says,
hey, I have this bug,
the app crashes for me, maybe
it would be nice if you say,
thanks, we'll look
into the problem.
And then after you've fixed it,
you can reply again to the user
and say, hey, we've
actually fixed that bug.
Please check it and let us
know if it's working for you.
And developers have seen
great response from users.
Users are usually very happy
to have this excellent customer
service.
And because your replies
are posted publicly,
if you respond to a review,
other users going to the store
and looking at
your app will say,
wow, this company
is very responsive.
OK, so one of the
most powerful tools
that we have in Google Play
is this idea of beta testing
and staged rollouts.
So we've seen over 80,000
apps use beta testing
and staged rollouts
to increase quality.
And we're seeing more
and more every day.
In fact, the majority of
our top apps on the store
use beta testing and staged
rollouts to increase quality.
And we see that
the average rating
for apps who have
done beta testing
is much higher than the average.
So let's talk about what each of
these different concepts mean.
So the whole idea
behind beta testing
is that you can do a
private test of your app.
So the idea is here, you
can create a Google group
or a Google+ community, and
users can opt in to view
the beta software.
You also get two
different versions
that you can test
simultaneously.
We call one alpha, and
one of them is beta.
And to prevent any leaking of
features or people sharing bugs
or things like that, we actually
make it so that those users
in the alpha and the beta
cannot actually leave reviews.
So this means if you're
testing some early software
with a small group
of beta testers,
this won't have any negative
impact on your reviews.
And later, you're actually
able to compare the statistics.
So for example, you can see how
different metrics like crashes
vary between your alpha
and beta versions.
Now, once you've tested
it with a small group
and you're ready to roll
out to a larger population,
you can use staged rollouts.
So the idea here is that
when you release an update
to your app, you
should be pretty sure
that it's going to work great.
But occasionally, we
all have that worry
that what if there's a bug?
So staged rollouts lets
you put the new version out
to a small group of users.
And so if you do find that
there is an issue early on,
like let's say users start
leaving bad reviews saying
that they don't
like the new version
or you notice a high
rate of crashing,
you can just stop the rollout
right there, fix the bug,
and then move on.
So it keeps bugs from
impacting your whole user base.
One common thing that
developers ask me a lot
is, tell me what I
should do on my app next.
And so to try to make this
advice as scalable as possible,
we have a new area that we call
optimization tips and alerts.
So what you decide to work on
next can be influenced by this.
So if we notice any
opportunities for your app
to improve, we'll give
you an optimization tip.
So an example of
this might be maybe
you have an app with a lot of
installs in, let's say, Russia,
but your app is not
translated into Russian.
We'll actually let you know.
And then it's easy to
purchase a translation
into that new language.
And this can be a great way
to make sure that you haven't
missed any opportunities.
Similarly, if we notice a
problem with your application,
we'll also let you know.
So let's say that you publish
a new version of your app,
and we notice that your
user reviews are much
lower than your older versions.
So we'll actually give
you an alert and say,
you should check this.
Maybe there's a problem.
You can also sign up to receive
emails so that you find out
about these alerts faster.
So once you understand how
your app is doing overall,
you want to
understand what users
are doing inside your app.
And the easiest way to do
that is Google Analytics.
Google Analytics is
also very helpful,
because it works cross platform.
You may have an Android
app, but maybe also
apps on other platforms,
and maybe a website as well.
And Google Analytics
lets you measure users
across all of these platforms.
So with just three
easy lines of code,
you can add Google
Analytics to your app.
And from there, you can get a
lot of detailed information.
So one example of
what you can do
once you've integrated
Google Analytics
is Google Tag Manager.
So once you understand what
users do inside your app,
you probably want to
make little tweaks to it.
And so Google Tag
Manager actually
lets you run experiments.
So for example, I could
have two versions of my app.
Maybe in one case, the
character in the game is a dog
and in another case, maybe the
character in the game is a cat.
And I could do a test
to see whether users
like cats or dogs better.
And then if I say I want to
maximize a certain metric,
like let's say revenue or
time spent in the game,
then the metric I
choose will be used
to determine whether the
cat or the dog character
is the winner.
And over time, it will
switch more and more people
over to the version that gives
the result that I prefer.
A common question
that users ask a lot
is, I would like to know how
people find my application.
And one of the best
ways to do this
is the Google Play
Referral Flow Report.
And this is a unique
feature that you
can get if you're using
Google Analytics in your app.
This allows you to track the
effectiveness of each campaign
that you run on Google Play.
So for every single
campaign that you have,
you can see how many users view
your app in the Play Store,
how many install your app,
and how many launch your app.
And this allows you to
track that conversion funnel
and understand which campaigns
perform best so that you can
optimize your marketing
budget and invest more
in the campaigns that work well.
OK, so another
sophisticated thing
that Google Analytics
can do for you
is allow you to define
the segments of your users
that are most valuable, and
then track them over time
and compare them to
the average user.
So for example, I
can say that I'm
very interested in users who
have gotten to level seven
in my game, have
spent more than $5,
and installed my
application in December.
And I can track that
group of users over time
and see how they respond to
different changes in the app
or to see how many of them
stay engaged in the long term.
We've seen a lot of
developers on Google Play
be able to grow their revenue
into significant businesses,
and so we've given much
more advanced reporting
around revenue.
So in addition to showing
you total revenue,
we also show the average
revenue per paying
user, the number of
buyers, and also allow
you to see breakdowns by country
of how much different revenue
you're making in each market.
And this can be really
helpful as you're
distributing your apps
and games globally
and you want to understand
the financial performance
of each market.
One common request that
we had from developers,
especially those who have
a large number of apps
or a large number of languages,
is that updating your apps
was getting pretty
time consuming.
So if you're spending a
lot of time doing updates,
especially if you have a lot of
apps or a lot of translations
into different languages,
the developer publishing API
may be helpful for you.
So it's able to
upload your APKs,
you can manage alpha
and beta testing,
you can upload your
localized graphics and text,
and it can be very
helpful to make sure
that you don't make any mistakes
in the publishing process
and that you can spend more time
building great apps and games
rather than uploading them.
OK, so today we talked about
how to incorporate quality
at every stage of making
a great app or game,
so in the design process,
the development process,
and the distribution process.
As you all learn much
more about Google Play,
I definitely encourage you to
check out the different tools
that we have available,
think about including
material design in your app,
and listening to your user
feedback.
Thank you.